wir haben lange gebraucht und überhaupt
uns mal klar zu machen krone hat auch
gesellschaftliche nebenwirkungen also
werden lange sozusagen ausschließlich
auf das medizinische problem gestartet
war am anfang sicher auch richtig aber
dann irgendwann gemerkt gut für kinder
und jugendliche ist das nicht so gut gar
nicht zur schule zu gehen und nicht in
der uni sein zu können und immer nur zu
hause wir haben gemerkt für die
wirtschaft ist das dann doch irgendwie
ein problem und für die kultur auch wenn
monatelang also nach unklaren kriterien
geschlossen wird und nachdem der
anfänglich einem wahnsinns zustimmung
hatten zu reinen maßnahmen also bis 80
prozent fanden am anfang so den harten
kurs und jetzt wird was getan über es
anders als in der flüchtlingskrise 2005
wir jetzt noch etwas getan jetzt gibt
konkrete maßnahmen konkrete vorschriften
super kann man uns daran halten klasse
das haben die deutschen also in ihrer
150% mentalität begeistert mitgemacht
aber dann langsam schleicht sich das
natürlich doch ab dann leidet man unter
der widersprüchlichkeit und
man fängt an sich zu fragen gefällt es
manchen leuten vielleicht einfach zu gut
dass wir diesen zustand haben wo die
politik ja doch einige an gewissen wie
soll ich sagen herablassende form und im
ton entwickelt hat gegenüber dem bürger
also sozusagen also dann wenn ich da an
die diversen impfkampagnen und so denke
dann da hatte ich da häufig das gefühl
sich auf kindergartenniveau angesprochen
zu werden inzwischen haben wir eine
situation da hat sich das wirklich
umgekehrt haben also eine erschreckende
umfrage
bearbeiteten letzten woche für die welt
23 prozent der deutschen sehen sich nach
einer repräsentativen umfrage von ihnen
seien inzwischen auf dem weg in die
diktaturen kann man immer darüber reden
darf man das so fragen überhaupt wie
wichtig sowie wie ernst muss man diese
repräsentativen umfragen den wir nehmen
sie in der regel schon relativ ernst
wenn wir versuchen herauszufinden wie
ist die stimmung im land und sie ist ja
auch sonst stech 46 prozent sagen nach
einer yougov umfrage man darf in
deutschland seine meinung nicht mehr
frei sagen und das ist findet sich
gerade an diesen pro monat das kennt ja
jeder aus dem freundeskreis auch also
wie hacker zum teil bis zur sache geht
und wie sehr das freundschaften auch auf
zerbrechen ich will jetzt dieses mainz
thema hatte einst war auch im
vergangenen jahr schon so die einst
bacher haben auch gefragt wie geht es
ihnen jetzt mit corona nach dieser
langen zeit 83 prozent gesagt das
gesellschaftliche leben hat sich sehr
verändert nicht zum vorteil in
deutschland 70 prozent haben das jahr 22
schon komplett abgeschrieben also
erwarten von dem gar nichts mehr und 60
prozent sagen die mir geht es selber
schlechter als
vor beginn der pandemie 1 prozent sagt
es geht uns besser und da möchte man
jetzt gar nicht populistisch und böse
zuspitzen unterstellen aber man hat so
ein bisschen das gefühl der
politikbetrieb der läuft ja einfach
weiter da finden die veranstaltungen
statt da hat man seine mitarbeiter da da
wie ist eigentlich nichts anders als
sonst und ich glaube dass das eine
latent immer vorhandene gefahr von
entfremdung zwischen politischen betrieb
und normalen menschen mit einem normalen
leben
doch noch weiter verschärft und an dem
punkt befinden wir uns jetzt war das ist
glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger punkt und
ein trend der leider schon länger am
laufen ist die allensbach-umfrage haben
das vertrauen in die institutionen der
bundesrepublik unter demokratie
überhaupt schon relativ lange immer
wieder abgefragt und die kurve ist
stetig sinkt beziehungsweise steigend
was das misstrauen betrifft norbert
röttgen hat man von systemischer
erschöpfung gesprochen das hat bei der
flüchtlingskrise in den riesen knacks
bekommen weil man sagte plötzlich gelten
diese regeln nicht mehr und das hat
jetzt eben auch noch mal so einen knacks
bekommen und man hat den eindruck als
ein bisschen wie so ein sediment sich da
immer wieder schichten drauf tragen weil
die leute sagen ja grundrechte dann
werden sie plötzlich abgeschafft weil es
gerade nicht passt das kann doch nicht
wahr sein und man hat auch inzwischen
den eindruck das ist eine bestimmten
typus politiker nicht nur herr
lauterbach gibt die sich irgendwie in
die rolle des nothelfer verliebt haben
so nach dem motto lasst mich durch ich
bin arzt und werde ich gebraucht
und im prinzip nicht davon lassen können
man man ist da völlig fasziniert wenn
man immer wieder erklärt bekommt das
also noch die wand bevorsteht der strick
erklärt ganz gut dass der anstieg längst
gebrochen ist und eigentlich jetzt das
ganze ab fällt nein wir müssen noch
warten und es könnte immer noch
schlimmer kommen und wer weiß was im
herbst noch ist und das ist die
psychologische dimension die wir an
gespielt wird in dieser ganzen
geschichte und das macht mir schon
einige sorgen dass uns die leute von der
stange gehen die einfach sagen ja gut
also das land das ist es jetzt auch
nicht mehr und was die da machen da oben
das betrifft mich alles nicht man kriegt
das immer schwerer wieder
zusammengehören und es ist eben zutiefst
beunruhigend also wie sehr die
parlamente ihre verantwortung auch
abgegeben haben an die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz an die
exekutive
lässig dann doch letzten endes das
bundesverfassungsgericht mit dem
verhältnismäßigkeit problem umgegangen
ist also das war ja praktisch dann doch
rückblickend zumindest eine karte auf
wie die
bundestagspräsidentin also gewählte
gesunde abgeordnete auf die tribüne des
bundestags verband und ihnen damit de
facto natürlich die freie aus im jahr
als erste ihres mandats erschwert das
also dass sowas keinen aufschrei keinen
größeren gibt dass er statt mit
nachgerade und dann natürlich sozusagen
das
ob das nun das rk ii war und der
gesundheitsminister davon wusste oder
nicht wusste ist es eigentlich gleich
schlimm also man verändert man über
nacht den chinesen den status von von
sechs auf drei monate übrig zunächst mal
nicht für bundestagsabgeordnete dass
auch ein ganz starkes stück ist dann
weiß man nichts davon wie ja herr
lauterbach also auch so also sehr
improvisiert einmal interessant
improvisiert mit zahlen nicht ob es
darum geht wer da auf den
intensivstationen die ich dann wusste er
mal ganz genau das sind die 47 48 ring
ich kann mich erinnern dass wir also
viele kollegen verzweifelt recherchiert
haben um mal raus zu kriegen wenn liegt
denn man auf die statistik ein aber er
wusste ist er wusste wie sehr die
krankheit kindern schadet obwohl das
glaube ich immer noch also
prozente sind und jetzt sie weiß ja dass
500 menschen am tag sterben werden wenn
wir jetzt also irgendwie ein eröffnungs
perspektive die unsere nachbarländer
alle machen veranstalten also ich kann
mir das zehrt alles aus und am anfang
haben die leute das vielleicht auch
nicht so schwer genommen nach dem motto
ich kann ja noch einkaufen gehen also
grundrechte haben ja auch leider was
sehr abstrakt ist müssten die viel
konkreter fühlen und leben aber langsam
summiert sich das doch wir holen hier
auch die sicht der unternehmer war denn
in diesen lagen aber unternehmer
generell die haben ja auch so viele
unternehmen in diesem land auch
selbstständige haben ja auch gelitten
vor allem auch natürlich dadurch dass
auch viele geschäfte eingebrochen
absolut also das thema vertrauen in die
politik spüre ich natürlich auch bei
unseren familienunternehmen dass da viel
verloren gegangen ist am anfang der
pandemie wusste niemand was auf uns
zukommt da hat man noch richtung
regierung geschaut da hat man auch
dieses pragmatische handeln am anfang
noch wirklich gut geheißen das hat uns
wirklich sehr gut gefallen man hat
geschaut wie können wir jetzt damit
umgehen
dann haben die unternehmer natürlich das
was die politik sagt verfolgt und auch
befolgt das heißt viel eigenkapital
investiert in corona schutzmaßnahmen
mitarbeitern und ins home office
geschickt geschaut dass die betriebe
weiter am laufen bleiben und nach ihr
jetzt mittlerweile zwei jahren sind
viele unternehmer einfach sehr
frustriert dass regel wirrwarr dass wir
haben die unterschiedlichen maßnahmen
das investierte eigenkapital da ist auch
wirklich viel ärger frust und verloren
gegangenes vertrauen das ist schon
wahnsinn und es ist schlimm zu sehen und
deswegen hoffe ich bzw es wird ein
großes stück arbeit seien jetzt von
seiten der politik von seiten der
regierung dieses vertrauen auch wieder
herzustellen
ja also ich die die das problem ist ja
sozusagen unbestritten und ich glaube es
hat zwei komponenten jetzt gerade in der
korona entwicklung und einer krone ab
anämie das eine ist das ist einfach
widersprüchliche ansätze gab also ich
kann das nur aus hamburg da hat dann der
senat beschlossen dass man beim laufen
um die alster um maske tragen soll oder
auf der einen straße bis hausnummer 25
und danach nicht mehr man durfte ohnehin
nur bis 10 uhr laupichler ja es gab dann
wird doch immer nicht mehr joggen
zufällige uhrzeit allein auf einer bank
sitzen soll ja sich sportlich betätigt
viel harmonie war voll aber im fussball
stein dann durfte man nicht gehen das
sind auch glaube ich so sachen das ist
gar nicht unbedingt böser wille immer
oder irgendwie ideologische verblendung
sondern einfach schlecht gemacht der
das meine ich wo bleibt der aufschrei
bei der politik hat nicht wirklich ich
warte darauf dass ein junger politiker
in der runde sitzt und richtig sagt es
reicht aber die politik sagt immer ja
vielleicht war es falsch gemanagt muss
man danach ist ihm also ehrlich man muss
doch auch mal sagen es reicht kein
politiker funktionen tag ist reich aber
es reicht doch langsamer sich bei den
maßnahmen die ich gerade genannt haben
wir das getan hamburg als cdu und haben
da auch sehr deutlich gesagt das geht so
nicht dass damit zerstört man eben
vertrauen so aber es die bild greift
dann auch gerne auf andere dann zum teil
eben nicht so aber es ist natürlich
wichtig dass das auch angesprochen wird
das ist ja auch unser system das eben
kritik geübt werden kann dort wo sie
dann berechtigt ist und am ende gibt es
eben waren aber ich würde denen den
zweiten aspekt auch noch mal nennen
wollen ganz wichtig ist und das
bestätigen ja auch mehrere umfragen dass
immer mehr leute angst haben das zu
sagen was sie denken und das hat viel
glaube ich mit politischer korrektheit
zu tun das war auch ganz stark in der
debatte um die migration da hat es mich
wahnsinnig gestört egal was man gesagt
hatte man musste immer tapsen gerade
wenn man noch irgendwie eine politik und
öffentlichkeit unterwegs war habe ich
mich persönlich auch zum teil wirklich
eingeschränkt gefühlt weil man
vernünftige position hat und jedenfalls
selber auch davon überzeugt dass es geht
gar nicht darum irgendwie
ausländerfeindlich zu sein oder so aber
einfach auch eine kritische position zu
haben zu dem was passiert ist und dann
zum teil gibt es leute die sagen der
soll dann aus seinem job raus dass er
gekündigt werden dann wird beim
arbeitgeber angestellt und das ist ein
riesenproblem was wir auch angehen
müssen aus meiner sicht und das dass das
geht so nicht da muss schluss sein
und es sind ja glaube ich zwei weitere
punkte noch die die leute wahnsinnig
machen das eine ist dass die kritik an
den maßnahmen die an sehr man ja sehr
vernünftige viele gründe für einzelne
sachen sind ziemlich pauschal als rechts
apostrophiert wurde also wer das
kritisierte war irgendwie ein rechter
waren sportler waren spinner also hat
von anfang an die proteste eigentlich
stigmatisiert so dass für sehr viele
normale nicht sportler nicht spinner
nicht nazis eine richtige
repräsentations lücke entstanden ist sie
fühlten sich bei keiner partei so
richtig aufgehoben wenn sie mit der afg
nicht so gerne was zu tun haben wollten
vor bei der fdp ein bisschen aber die
ist jetzt natürlich sehr auf
regierungskurs oder oder zahnrad
eingeschwenkt können froh sein dass sie
kubicki noch haben und ansonsten war es
einfach schwierig also dass genau dieses
also man man sagt dann lieber gar nichts
also bevor man jetzt rechts ist erhält
man über den mond leider ist und das
andere war hat ja eine sehr
monolithische front also viele unserer
kollegen da müssen wir jetzt vielleicht
hier in dieser runde nicht zu
selbstkritisch sein aber es ist doch
wirklich ein ziemlich starkes
regierungssprecher syndrom unter unter
journalisten aus du brauchst du mal ist
ja auch inhaltlich gar nicht stimmte
also eine der größten impfgegner
klienten kommen aus dem ökologischen
bereich die ohnehin auf homöopathie und
heilpraktiker setzen und immer schon
befremdet haben mit mit chemischen
arzneimitteln und impfungen auch also
das gab's also lange vor corona dass es
in bestimmten milieus einen riesen
abwehr dagegen gab die sind aber ganz
gewiss nicht rechts und dann hat man
einfach übersehen oder als als typisch
konservative linken bashing betrachtet
wenn man da auf die einigermaßen
zivilisiert auf die homöopathie freaks
eingedroschen hat das ist schon eine
komische geschichte also aber das große
problem was dahinter steht ist natürlich
ein in einer freiheitlichen gesellschaft
einen sich selbst organisierende
konformitätsdruck der dazu führt dass
wenn du nicht ganz fit bist rhetorisch
und ihr irgendetwas rausrutscht du ganz
schnell an die wand genagelt wird obwohl
er einfach nur fragen hast sorgen hat
bedenken und hast das recht ungelenk
ausgedrückt und das betrifft corona das
betraf aber damals auch die migrations
krise das betrifft ganz in ganz starkem
maße die ganze gender thematik wurde
sagt irgendwie du findest das komisch
mit diesem sternchen und dann ist man
bis man den trans feind und wir haben
früher mal das hat irgendwas mit der
transportbranche
dass das ist eigentlich ganz bizarr
obwohl man einfach als normaler mensch
vor sich hin lebt und am ende sagt man
sich dann hältst lieber den mund kriegst
du musst wieder debatten und die globes
sind auch zum teil sehr militant